now going back my fear hi and welcome to
on an actual Friday hey high five
let's do it why would you not - me
anyway I'm back in Italy so I thought
it's about time that I open some mail
because I have a lot of it
cosmopolitan thank you I am a big fan of
boobs
why why we said with it have I ever
mentioned anywhere that I read custom
but it's in Dutch anyway I was supposed
to read it actually I guess I just look
at that I have a girlfriend
okay oh good more why would you send me
a bunch of cosmopolitan uh uh I would
like I should send Katie something
Nick's package hey awesome
look at that I love it next package
hahaha
oh no way bras look at this it's so
awesome seriously I would I will go in
public i'ma wear this at VidCon and it's
not an epic but it's kind of kind of the
same
it's a Bulbasaur cat am i cold yet
next package bros are you cereal right
now wait shirt that is not what your
picture open season
World of Warcraft breasts talking
Britain right another brands diamonds
good I guess I gotta play Bratz
huh celebrate sense celebration stuff
Mini Ninjas this game is [ __ ] awesome
huh thank you I love that game
I'm playing this game right now oh by
the way when I came back from from LA I
forgot to do back up on my shave so I
have to replay everything that we've
done so far and that's why it's taking
me a little longer so so sorry that I
haven't played it right away I want it I
want to continue it Tomb Raider legend
oh my god we are playing this one
there's a letter to dear feet bye thank
you for making all the awesome video
don't worry about it thank you for
setting me high school music oh good why
would anyone buy this I forget okay
anyway you are always making me smile
even at my worst day Wow don't bend
sweet I hope you enjoy the games and the
Norwegian candy where's the Norwegian
candy where's the gnome a mechanic I
only got the game leave Armagnac leave a
comment which came out of all dc1 maybe
you want to see me play in the future
but for now no way I love it I didn't
know they had plushies for conquer [ __ ]
yeah
thank you Conker's Bad Fur Day was a
[ __ ] epic let's play I love that game
that's awesome thank you bro you know
what I'm gonna I'm gonna put them here
congratulations
with all your success I haven't
succeeded at anything I don't understand
you make all your wash your smile and
laugh that I guess that's something
thank you every day I wake up excited
for a new video to brighten up my day
currently I've been facing some
difficulties but because of your silly
crazy self you put a smile on my face oh
that is adorable not just anyone can do
that you have a gift
talents stop it next package okay so
apparently this is for cry it says that
finally cries favorite candy
our and I'm supposed to give this to him
ah and I get of course the swedish fish
Kalam Swedish you know what I have a
secret for you breasts thank me hi hello
I'm from Bulgaria I currently live in
Belgium I'm big fan I mean bro uh
however I decided to make this painting
I hope you like it
I also hope it won't scare the [ __ ] out
of you if you ever hang it anywhere but
I know kids got balls of steel
I got balls at all also when you had
this
it's called Martin Itza she drives with
her away and brings spring so I guess
I'm supposed to wear this to bring
winter away how do I look
get that pits we haven't finished
playing yet oh now I don't think she
kind of Awesome it's kind of scary cuz
I'm sitting down right now oh [ __ ] you
can't really see it ah
this is in the background hey kids thank
you so much bro all right I'll hang this
in the bathroom second so I can take a
[ __ ] without having to take a [ __ ] next
package whoa what the [ __ ] is this huh
this is my I think it is so much panic
and eye candy don't judge me okay Russ
say cheese okay oh oh
so gingerbread says there's nothing like
a homemade batch of Christmas cookie it
fits I hope you like this package we
thought you are you instantly when we
saw it we freaking loved watching your
videos we watch them every day we look
forward to more videos they awesome bro
brofist from your bridge hat chose Marc
Amy and Mirai alright let's see what
they send me Oh
and that's how you model I'm ready for
my night out
gotta get some ladies eyebrows that's
all the time I had to open mail today
hope you bros enjoyed watching I would
just want to say thank you both so much
for all the mail I really appreciate it
I'm sorry I can't open all of it but hey
that's I'm just I'm just a man anyway
thank you both so much for the support
it always makes me really like heart
warm and happy to see all the support in
real life I guess through all the mail I
really appreciate it you brother always
shown so much LA than somewhere support
and I feel like I don't deserve it
good I feel I feel guilty almost but
anyway I try to repay you by making
videos I guess I don't know um either
way thank you both so much
stay awesome I know you will
cerimon activate
beer
you I don't know if you even like me
I don't know even